hey guys this is Cameron with motion
science I am back with another really
quick video it's been a crazy hectic
week for me so I'm just putting together
a very quick video for you to check out
this week this one has to do with 3d
cameras and 3d layers again I've gotten
so much feedback about the 3d camera and
3d layer videos that I thought it would
be great to expand a little bit more on
what I know about those two subjects and
one of those things I want to talk about
this week is how to work with a whole
lot of 3d layers and not feel out of
control with your timeline and let me
show you what I mean if you look at
these two comp in dough's here you can
see that it's just a bunch of blue
squares position back in Z red squares
and green squares and if I pull up the
timeline here you're gonna see that
there's forty three layers fourty two
layers of solids plus the camera layer
so let me show you my trick what we're
gonna do is take all the red solids
we're gonna right click and select
precompose and we'll name it red
pre-comp
I'm gonna do the same thing with the
blue layers pre-compose
and the same thing with the green layers
right-click pre-compose so now we have
four total layers instead of forty-three
forty-four layers we have four a red a
blue and a green pre-comp and a camera
so if I go with my camera tool here and
I move side to side nothing happens
right well if I make these three pre
comps 3d there they are and I can move
back and forth but they're treated as
like a solid single 3d layer and we can
see that here so the trick here is to
just go into this column right here it's
called collapse transformations if I
just collapse each one of these you'll
see how they expand out and boom they
are dimensional 3d layers go back over
here I'll show you just like that the
other really cool thing about this is
that collapse transformations still
takes advantage of the lights in 3d
space so I'll add a parallel light and
you can see here that the light is still
affecting the layers but we're only
dealing with three layers instead of 42
layers so that's my tip for the week I
hope you learned something new
leave a comment below let me know what
you think and until next time I'm
Cameron and this is motion science
[Music]
Oh